you got you got chicks that are doing
only fans yeah selling their body online
making a lot of money because of Sims
again and then obviously even they will
have high expectations because they oh
I'm making 10 racks a month so uh you
know I need to be with a guy that makes
x amount bruh like it just kind of
messes up the whole game like women are
looking down on nine to five yeah
can't win I've done so many reaction
videos to women saying ah nah if a guy
does 95 he they would rather they'd
actually rather date a criminal a
scammer yes then date a guy that does
nine to five because oh if I just want
to go to Italy at the drop of a hat he
can't do that he has to ask his boss and
yeah I need a guy that's an entrepreneur
or a scammer bro this is unrealistic
boss